5 months on huge crowds still turn up in
solidarity with nisha's current military
rulers the post president Muhammad bazum
remains captive and the Jinta shows no
haste to come up with a clear plan to
restore democracy both key demands of
the regional block
Echo public affairs analy s suadu
believes the Jun won't succumb to
pressure from Echo if if we accept what
eoas want it's meaning that we accept
what France wants and this is not the
scenario we are we are we can
accept he thinks it could be another two
years before the current military
leadership leaves
power many here think echo's initial
threat to use Force Harden the junus
position and its supporters the believe
former colonial power France was behind
the threat of force and the sanctions
that are crippling the local
economy Echo is not only concerned about
the possibility of more CPS in the
region it's worried it could fragment
three member countries where the
military is in power have formed the
alliance of sahal states and that's
considered a threat to the future of the
block but some say the sahelian alliance
won work toa's
Advantage the has no capacity to
continue Define the International
Community considering its landlocked
nature if you rely on others for
something you'll eventually give in to
certain
demands an active Civil Society had
previously forced past Coe leaders to
quickly return the country to democracy
some analysts believe history will
repeat itself if the current leaders
overstay their
welcome but with the support Nas Juna
currently enjoys after ordering France
out it's not clear if the Civil Society
here will live up to their past
reputation ahammed rris Al jazer
n make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer